thank you alejandro i am with a legend
of american chess joel benjamin joel
first of all welcome back to st louis
welcome back to the show how does it
feel to be playing over the board chess
once again
it feels kind of weird because my last
tournament was in november and i played
very very sparingly
so
i think i need the first few rounds to
to kind of get warmed up
and um you know
i've had some pretty good positions but
um
you know when we get late in the
struggle
i have to have that energy you know be
able to summon up that energy to to put
them through it's still a much better
start compared to last year last year
was pretty rough in the first few rounds
i was very conscious of that to make you
know that it was okay if i have a modest
start but i have to avoid that disaster
in the beginning and i think that i'll
be stronger towards the end absolutely
and let's take a look at today's game
how did you approach today's round
well um i guess one of my favorites i
played kaidanov many times uh
historically i have an excellent score
with white and a very poor score with
black
so
he's also maybe the hardest opponent to
beat with white in the tournament so
it's kind of like
the edge that i get with the white
pieces is small
but the big advantage is not having the
black pieces because that's going to be
a rough ride
but the games that i've won from him
generally have not been because of the
opening and um you know
all of us are trying to think of just
some way to get out of the opening with
that without him just totally
neutralizing because his his opening
repertoire is incredibly tight
do you see him as probably the most
dangerous player in this field when it
comes to opening preparation
yes
yes uh because he's just he's almost
he's almost unbeatable you have to you
have to manage to get
uh to get a position to play and i kind
of thought that i did that and then
uh you know suddenly after queen d5 i
realized that he's got another one of
those you know kaidana of liquidating
sequences and he's calculated all the
tactics and
well let me
if you don't mind let me take back a
couple of moves okay absolutely to start
with the position of the bishop d2
knight 35 rook e8
bishop to d2 i've had this position
before okay i had this position against
vanderstern in 1994.
vanderstern uh was a similar kind of cat
to kaidanov he answered e4 with e5 and
d4 with d5 so i did the same thing c4 e6
e4 and i got to this position
which he he thought
was nothing uh special but he played
here night before and after knight e4
he regretted that move because the
tactics are suddenly
a big problem so he had to go knight
back to d5 he just lost a lot of time
so i had this position on the on the
board
this morning but you did spend 15
minutes up to this point
where you yeah well i'm not andrew i'm
not andrew haan you know
no nobody is played bishop d2 but i was
also thinking about the uh
you know sometimes i get this type of
position i try to channel norman's mises
because norman's mises is the high
priest of this variation okay he plays
this all the time he opens with c4
and probably like two-thirds of his
opponents play e6 because they want to
try out this opening
and uh
i've seen a lot of games he displays
knight e2 just avoids the train he
brings knight to g3 just keeping tension
in the position but then i thought
bishop d2 okay you know i just couldn't
help just connecting my rooks you know
before um
you know before doing anything
and uh
i didn't anticipate knight takes c3
because the engine said that knight c7
was the best move and i didn't look at
the second best move so i'm really
probably the engine just thought that
knight takes c3 is is a very small
advantage you didn't think about knight
c3 like andrew hung in the shower
the problem is that that i
i don't look at one opening obsessively
and i looked at a few different things
that might happen of course there's many
there's many ways that black can play
this opening
i could not find a single game on the
database that kaidana faced c4 and e4
so i i didn't know what i thought that
you were going to surprise you
i i'm sure i didn't you probably did i
definitely surprised him um and he
played in the most conventional way not
necessarily the best way black has all
many other good options but um yeah i'm
kicking myself for not not looking at
this in advance because maybe i could
have thought something of something to
do but here
um
you know i i tried to calculate queen f5
at queen d3 but just somehow
my piece is just in the wrong place he
has
you know there's a problem that um
you know that some lines he can
no i that that
no no rookie six i thought rookie six is
is what he does on queen f5 that was the
problem i didn't know how to answer
rookie six
because
do you have some funny ideas knight
takes f7 probably not but okay but right
now i'm pinned after c4 sorry okay but
then queen takes d4
and and and uh queen takes
and rook takes e1 yeah right i have two
i have all my pieces hanging and queen
takes d2 yeah so knight f7 doesn't work
yeah so i couldn't see how to organize
it i couldn't see how to get in the move
c4
um i thought about queen d3
um i thought he could maybe play c5
you know rook rook d8 is also possible
c5 maybe is the most annoying
i just didn't see anything
i don't know if the engines have any
better ideas than i did but no no i
think the engine wanted to go into the
uh
as you did well but also now i saw c4
knight b4 and then i was racking my
brain about i could have tried c4 first
and then knight d7
uh i realized that later and if knight
before maybe knight d7 is possible but i
think that basically yeah not a lot just
start for you three draws are we about
to see fireworks in the next few rounds
well i i hope that i'm going to put a
win on the board
and um feeling just a little bit better
every day
and
you know hopefully
next time i'm here i'll have you know
something more to talk about
guys
joe i got a quick question for you yeah
one of the great benefits of course of
being a commentator is i get to
sacrifice all of your pieces
did it ever occur to you to sacrifice an
exchange rook takes e6 f takes e6 queen
d3 and just play the position
uh i got it on oh sorry uh you
i don't see the position yet
there you go so you just play rook i
mean yeah i know i know the engine the i
know i saw this on the engine but i
didn't understand it so i didn't want to
do it
[Laughter]
well you just play bishop h6 bishop d2
rookie one mesh medinav channel your
inner nash medina yeah i mean nobody has
tried this over the board i did i did
see it come up on the engine okay but i
just didn't i just didn't know what to
make of it
and i thought i could just uh you know
just play normal moves but
um
it is a possibility i was wondering if
it was even possible to take on e6
immediately when he played bishop e6 but
that i did not i did not look on the
computer at that which i was kind of
kicking myself that you know um but um
but i was thinking about uh that but um
i don't know um
well you got to make a nostradamus out
of me because i've chosen you to win the
tournament so i don't want to put the
pressure on you
it's time to perform daily
isn't going to cut it
you got to win well the thing is the
thing is um
for me
the tournament is not about um
about
just playing ability
i don't worry about that i'm just
worried about um you know physical and
chess conditioning that's that's the
biggest obstacle for me
and you know i'm just i'm managing it
day by day and so if i can conquer that
then i you know maybe can start putting
some wins on the board but you know you
you have to realize the oscar that i'm
i'm you know in the in the top group of
rustiest players in the in the field
so that makes me kind of a long shot
all right i like it thank you joel
though thank you the the the the top
half of the rusty field
we see here our picks before the senior
championship
joel benjamin hey i'm telling you joel
he's coming yeah he's coming appreciated
he he's playing himself with the forum
you see that
confidence
coming it's beginning to brew the brew
the brew is happening
thank you joel thank you joel